Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at a
API developer platform called WunderGraph.
And to guide us on today's journey, I
am joined by the founder,
Jens.
Good evening, Jens. How's it going? Good evening.
Nice. You helped me on the on the
show.
Yeah. I'm excited. I always love to play
with really cool technology.
And I think what makes this extra special
is like I was actually playing an experiment
with with with WunderGraph before we even discussed
doing a session together. And I was like,
this is really cool. Like, we we need
to to show this to people and and
and share it. So before
we talk about WunderGraph and
what that is and get started with the
hands on demo today, Could you just give
us the TLDR on who is Jens, what
you're up to, and anything else you wish
to share?
Sure.
Yeah. I'm Jens, the founder of WunderGraph. I'm
34.
I have two kids,
Leonie and Janik, one and three,
which are also in my avatar. I think,
like, family is probably the most important thing
in in my life.
Plus WunderGraph,
You know? Like, I have, like, three kids,
if you wanna say so.
But yeah.
I I think
the the and
the the the important bit here is
why WunderGraph?
And and if you look at my career,
I started
actually as an entrepreneur. I never studied
computer science or or anything. I wanted to
build a startup at the early age of
20.
I just wanted to build a startup, and
there was nobody who could build me an
iOS and an Android app, so I just
had to learn it myself. So there was
a guy on YouTube called Slide Nerd
from India
with the classic Indian accent. I I and
I learned Java from him, and it was
such a pain for the first couple of
months because I just didn't get computing and
and programming.
And yeah. But, eventually,
this whole thing, it turned into an app.
I learned
iOS programming and and Android. Later, I switched
to React Native.
I built my back end first in Java,
then I learned about Go.
And and, yeah, that startup eventually failed because
startups are hard, and we didn't have a
clue. But we learned a lot. And then,
yeah, I started,
like, a regular
career as a programmer,
turned architect
team lead.
And
through that career, I kind of learned the
the complexity of actually working with APIs.
And
at the last big company I worked for,
we had to integrate, like, 30 different services,
and it was a huge pain in the
ass. And we built our own REST APIs
and and
somehow cobbled everything together, the different
protocols
and and different APIs, and it was a
real mess.
And then I joined an API management company,
Tyke, where I learned a lot about API
gateways,
how they work, what they do, etcetera.
I was, like, two and a half years
at Tyke,
and I found that
there's a lot of, like, full stack developers
that don't know enough about API management,
and API management doesn't know enough about full
stack developers.
So what I wanted to create is a
developer experience
that puts together
full stack development,
API management,
and API integration. So I wanted to build
a toolset
where full stack developers
feel home.
They get the capabilities
of an API gateway
without
actually or without having the feeling of using
an API gateway.
Because if you talk API gateways like Thai,
Kong, Apigee, and so on and so forth,
These tools, they are user usually designed for
ops people. Like, you have a dashboard. You
configure it. It's like very heavyweight introducing
an API gateway to your stack. It's a
it's a complex thing, and it it completely
changes your architecture.
What I wanted to create with WunderGraph is
a simplified
architecture where you leverage
capabilities
of an API gateway,
but it still feels like you're just doing
full stack. So when you when you use
WunderGraph,
it looks more or less or very similar
to something like Next. Js, but you actually
have an API gateway. You have a back
end. You can put custom codes, and you
have a lot of functionality that that helps
you with API integration,
that integrates with your identity providers,
that solves a lot of enterprise
use cases when when you want to scale
something that you would not normally find in
a framework like Next. Js. But it's,
yeah, it's it's kind of like a special
developer experience if you if you have some
experience
in in the market and and what what
kind of tooling and and patterns can be
used,
I would say it's kind of like a
combination of Next. Js,
a back end for front end pattern,
and an API gateway
all together
in in one user experience. It's all
TypeScript.
So we use Go behind the scenes
for for performance
reasons,
but the user experience is TypeScript, so everything
is configured in TypeScript.
We use infrastructure
as code patterns, so there's no
GUI. There's no dashboard because developers
don't like to click around. They want to
code. They want to put their stuff in
Git.
And,
yeah, it's kind of like everything I hated
throughout my career,
I try to do better, and the result
is WunderGraph.
Alright. Awesome. There is a lot to unpack
there. So thank you for sharing all of
that. What I'll say is I also have
two young kids, four and one. So I
feel your pain and then I fuck. Because
I couldn't imagine trying to build a start
up with kids that young. Must be tough.
But awesome.
Can I comment on that? Of course. Yeah.
You know, the the right time, like the
the right time to lose weight is is
never
The the right time to have kids is
never. The right time to start a startup
is also never. You just have to do
things like you know, if you have kids
and you're like, should I start a startup?
The answer would usually or always be no.
Just go to a corporate.
And I I just said, like, fuck it.
We're we're gonna do this. Like, you know,
I I
sometimes in your life I don't know who
who else feels like that, but sometimes in
in your life, you find yourself in a
situation where you're like, I cannot work
at a company anymore. I must do this.
This is my mission. Like, WunderGraph must exist.
And and, yeah, that's just
my personality.
Yeah. Awesome. Well, congratulations.
I wish you all the best of luck,
but I know you're not gonna need it
because I played with WunderGraph and it's fucking
awesome. So I also quit my job in
September saying fuck it as well, but you
know, it's not a startup thing. I'm just
a
consultant, I guess. So no, it doesn't feel
as risky when it's just me.
Anyway, back on track.
I don't even know where we were anymore.
Yes. Yes. You were talking about logical technologies.
So you mentioned go. So I'm a big
fan of go. I'm I'm a even bigger
fan of typescript and I am a
huge advocate of everything as code.
The job I quit was from Pulumi. So
I spent the last year of my life
doing infrastructure. Uh-huh.
Yeah. Pulumi is big inspiration
for WunderGraph because we we you know, when
I saw Pulumi, I was like, hey. I
I can create
a bucket, and I can create a service
all by writing some TypeScript, and then I
do pull me up. And I was like,
this is what we need for.
It's interesting. I didn't know. Yeah. I mean,
I've been infrastructure
as coding everything for many years. I've been
using
TypeScript as a language for defining Kubernetes objects
for years prior to that. Was just in
Terraform. I've played with CDKTF.
And if in that, can describe stuff as
code makes me a very, very happy person.
Even things like Prisma, although it's not a
readily code, but that DSL for database migrations,
I think is very cool.
So, yeah, when you say this has got
an API that gives you that API is
code kind of mentality or infrastructure is code
mentality to work with your APIs. It's something
that I'm very passionate about. Another project that
I've been exploring a lot lately is Dagger,
which is CICD pipelines as code as well
using TypeScript. I always seem to come back
to TypeScript because and I'm assuming this is
one of the reasons that you probably picked
it in the project. It's just it's got
that right balance of approachable and accessible with
the tape semantics.
Like, you don't have to go learn the
borrow checker Rust for instance to get a
strongly typed system and TypeScript works really well.
I think it's a nice language for people
to to learn some of these more complex
intricacies of type based systems.
It's
an interesting topic because I actually like to
talk about
Rust, Go and TypeScript.
So for example,
the the gateway of WunderGraph, it's written in
Go, and I think it's the perfect language
because Go has this balance between it's crazy
fast,
and most of the time, you get it
right.
You don't need a borrow checker. Borrow checkers
are for super smart people who who solve
crazy hard problems.
We're just building an API gateway.
Yes. It's hard, but it's not
at the hard level.
Like, it's you know, we're not building an
aircraft or a tank. We're just getting
HTTP requests.
Go is perfect because it's it's much easier
to to
I feel super productive in Go. Whenever I
try to learn Rust, I feel very stupid.
And
TypeScript, on the other hand,
you know,
Go is
great if you do, like,
yeah, like, back end back end stuff. But
if you want to do something with the
user interface
or if you want to create code with
the user interface, like code as the interface,
I think TypeScript
with its rich
generic
capabilities,
it's the perfect language
for a user interface. If we think, you
know, not buttons, but for developers, the user
interface is the language. And I think TypeScript
is actually the best language
to create
amazing
developer experiences.
Like, that that's that's my love for for
TypeScript. So everything that should be super fast,
I would say,
Go. Everything that should be
pleasant to use, TypeScript, and everything that should
be super safe,
I would go Rust. But, yeah, for for
us, API gateway, Go is safe enough, I
would say.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, I don't wanna just keep talking
about programming languages all day. Although I'm more
than happy to sit and talk about all
three of those for the next three hours.
I do want us to to kind of
focus on WunderGraph and get hands on with
it. So we'll start the demo in a
few more minutes, but maybe we can give
you know, you kind of talked about
what it is or what you're trying to
achieve with it, but maybe we could be
very specific. What is that use case that
people should take away from today about why
they need to start using WunderGraph?
Yes.
So
I think one thing that's what I learned
in my career. One thing that is
probably true for every application
is
or every web application, you usually have a
front end, You have a back end, and
your back end doesn't talk
to a single database. That's almost never the
case.
What's more likely is your front end, you
have back end, and the back end talks
to hi, Jamie, by the way. The the
back end talks to
a database and a couple
other
services. Those could be internal services.
Those could be a partner APIs. Those could
be
third party services.
And one thing that's that's, like,
front and center to WunderGraph is the idea
of we have an opinion
on how you should put together
APIs.
And what that opinion does is,
you know, kind of like Laravel.
When Laravel was enough,
you had a structure of this is how
you write a controller, and you knew what
to do, and this is how you do
a migration.
And what we do
with APIs
is kind of like we're completely in the
stone age because
if you add APIs to a project,
it's kind of like implicitly
managing dependencies.
And, you know, for code,
like
Go, we have Go modules.
In Java, we have Maven.
And in in Node. Js, we have NPM.
And for APIs,
we have nothing. We just
do a fetch to Stripe
or we import an SDK.
And WunderGraph has an opinion here. We say,
we're not just an API gateway, and we're
not just a framework.
We try to be a package manager for
APIs,
and that changes everything because WunderGraph has the
concept of API dependencies.
So in WunderGraph, you can add APIs
as dependencies.
WunderGraph
turns all your API dependencies into a virtual
graph, which is simply
a GraphQL API.
And now you can treat
all these API dependencies like
a GraphQL API that's
only virtually exists because the moment you write
a GraphQL query,
we turn it into
adjacent RPC API because we treat security.
Like, security is super important for us. I
think most people shouldn't expose a GraphQL API.
So we kind of only use GraphQL
on the server
similar to SQL to talk to your API
dependencies.
And and that's, I think, the the
outstanding thing. That's the USP. That's what makes
WunderGraph
so different than anything else.
Okay. I'm gonna try and summarize that. And
if I get anything wrong, please correct me.
Yeah. So
WunderGraph gives me the ability to define external
APIs
as dependencies.
I'm assuming I point to some sort of
GraphQL API for introspection. I point to an
open
specification document
to understand that API. I don't know if
it supports other stuff. I know as there's
the database support as well. Those all get
created or
exposed as a virtual graph and the interface
for me and to other people to that
virtual graph is GraphQL. However,
you're parsing that GraphQL and then speaking JSON
RPC
to all the underlying
APIs below.
Was that was that correct? Did I get
everything wrong there? Almost.
So,
obviously, we talk
the language of the origin to the origin.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. But what we do
is on the front end side, we create
adjacent RPC API
that we also have
an an embedded
code generator.
So you define an operation,
like,
give me countries,
give me weather,
and combine that.
And from that, we generate an RPC endpoint,
and we generate a type safe client.
Because
one thing that I always found weird is,
you know, GraphQL is amazing because it's so
dynamic and you can query whatever you want.
But the moment you deploy something to production,
you will never change your queries because your
queries are not dynamic. Like, you have variables
where you can put an input at runtime.
But if you have a a view with
your your user
info
view,
you don't change the user info query at
runtime.
So
why would anybody want to expose a dynamic
API if you don't need a dynamic API
in production?
That's insecure. That's just,
yeah, making the the
the attack surface bigger. So that's that's why
WunderGraph by default,
like, just exposes
JSON RPC. And that's amazing because from JSON
RPC, we can also generate
an open API spec. We can generate a
postman collection.
So that means you add, like, three API
dependencies. You create a couple of operations.
You deploy that, and now you have a
Postman collection, and you can give that to
someone who wants to use your API. That
means they can just load it in Postman,
play with your API, and they don't have
to learn GraphQL. Because I think a lot
of people
just want to use your API, and there
should be as little friction as possible. And
not everybody wants and not everybody will learn
GraphQL.
Alright. Last question and then hands on, I
promise. So you mentioned something earlier,
back end for front end.
Yes. I think this is a term that
I definitely
am not that strong with, and I'm assuming
maybe other people in the audience may not
be that familiar with or understand what you
mean by that. But could you tell us
a little bit more about that pattern?
Yes. So
like a very common pattern in in enterprise
architecture is you have internal and external services,
and then someone says we need a new
project. We want to build an app. We
want to build a website.
And what you usually do is you
don't let this website talk to all the
services internal and external.
Instead,
you create a back end for front end,
so a specific back end for this front
end,
and it will supply the capabilities that only
this front end needs.
And
it's a very popular
pattern.
The problem is
if you look at frameworks like Redwood. Js
and others,
those always
assume
we have a database
as we're building something from scratch.
And it's not optimized for the use case
of we always we we already have APIs
like Stripe and Twilio and our database and
Kafka and whatnot.
And now we need an opinionated framework
to build a BFF.
So WunderGraph is optimized
for this use case where you say, okay.
I create I want to create a new
front end, and we already have a couple
of services
because,
obviously, everybody can build a back end for
front end from scratch. Just use, like, Fastify
or whatever you want. And then,
yeah, combine the services and do it manually.
But the question is,
do you actually want to invent
the right kind of patterns,
and do you want to think about how
to actually build a BFF, or do you
want to build on top of a framework
that
thinks about this topic for a couple of
years and the makers behind that and figured
out what are the what are the the
important bits
to to to do this in an efficient
way. And this way, you can
you can
not write a lot of code. Like, you
know, for from our business perspective, I I
think as a business, it's always super important
to write as little code as possible that
has nothing to do with your business. And
inventing patterns to create BFS,
that
shouldn't be like, you shouldn't be doing that.
Just
just built on top of something that already
works.
Sweet. On that, I think we'll go straight
over to the screen share, and we'll start
showing people what WunderGraph
can do.
Let's see.
What did we decide on again? Like, it's
going to be you. Right?
Yes. I think we agreed that I will
do Yeah. Okay. And we're gonna work through
some of the examples because there are quite
a few and the WunderGraph model repository.
Yes. I've got the website here and people
can find it at wundergraph.com.
Is a whole bunch of documentation,
but I think we're going straight to the
GitHub repository.
So let's get that. Yeah.
WunderGraph
and then WunderGraph again.
And by the way, one thing I can
mention is
WunderGraph is a % open source, Apache two
point o.
We believe in a healthy
community.
And,
yeah, there's no enterprise version or or anything.
So everything we talk about,
you can run it on your own. You
can debug everything, the Go part, the TypeScript
parts. It's everything is available.
Cool. But you are launching WunderGraph
close, right, to make it easier for people?
Yeah.
So the what what we do is very
similar to to Vercel.
WunderGraph, the framework itself,
I would call it, like, the the
Next. Js for back end.
And WunderGraph Cloud is, like, the the WunderGraph
to make it easy to
not do anything, just focus on coding.
That's my preferred approach.
So
are we working through this examples directory?
Yeah. So we have one example that's
Next. Js TypeScript
functions. So we recently added TypeScript functions, which
I think is so cool. So you can
go to that, and then you can
n p m I, and I think n
p m start,
and we should be good. Yeah.
Let's try it out.
Alright. So we have something running on
oh, it's open to. Yes.
So that's our
our
usual
starter package.
We already have an
operation
running
on the main page. That's Next. Js, and
we have WunderGraph running
behind the scenes. So that means we have
two services running.
And,
yeah. Maybe you wanna explore it a bit.
Okay. So I'm not I'm not sure what
I'm looking at. I'm looking at an XGS
website that is used speaking
to
the WunderGraph API
proxy.
Mhmm.
And if I push refresh, I'm not I
I I don't really know what's happening. So
maybe you can
Yeah. If you push refresh, it just
Says validating for truthful. One nanosecond.
Yeah. But the the SpaceX API, it's I
think it's static.
It's just a popular example when you use
a GraphQL APIs,
and that's why we put it here.
Yeah. So this is calling
the Dragon's operations endpoint on some service.
Exactly.
Alright. Let's take a look at the code.
Maybe that will
help me.
Okay. So when we push the refresh button,
we're calling dragons.mutate.
Dragons
is using use query from the WunderGraph generated
SDK,
I guess. Mhmm.
And I don't know what the operation Dragon
is coming from, but I'm assuming
there's something in here that defines that probably
in the GraphQL schema.
Is there a .WunderGraph
directory somewhere?
There is. It's just very small because the
size of the explorer, but it is here.
Yep. And I see operations.
Okay.
Okay. So you're proxying the SpaceX
API.
Correct.
Okay.
And here's something interesting.
If you look at line two.
Oh, yeah. You can make it a bit
bigger. That would definitely help the audience.
You see that k. I I I don't
know if you know the the SpaceX API,
but the SpaceX API itself,
it is
it has the root field dragons. But here,
we see SpaceX underscore dragons.
And if we go to the wundergaf.config.ts,
we can get some hints why this is
happening.
So here,
we are introspecting the APIs we're using.
Dragon starts from the SpaceX API,
and one concept we have is API namespacing.
So when we started
exploring
like, this is kind of like, I don't
know, a year ago or something. When we
started exploring
to automatically
combine APIs,
what we quickly found is that
when you try to combine multiple APIs, you
run into naming collisions.
And so to mitigate that and to to
not have the user manually
change APIs or or have to rename stuff,
you can put
each API into its own namespace,
and this way it's isolated.
So that means if you go to the
generated folder, we can actually look at the
the resulting
GraphQL schema when we combine everything. There's a
GraphQL schema file somewhere.
It's the only GraphQL file. Yeah. And then
if you go to the search for the
type query, then you can see our entry
points.
Yes.
And here you can see, okay, we have
the SpaceX APIs, and if you scroll a
bit more,
then you see here's countries and then weather.
And each of them is in their own
namespace types TypeScript. GraphQL has no namespacing by
itself,
so we can fix that on our own.
Okay. Do you expose,
like, GraphQL playground at a graphical or anything
like that for me to play around with
this?
Yes. You can go to
local host
port
nine nine nine one slash
GraphQL.
Okay. Cool.
So if I type query,
and I'm assuming the documentation
oh, nope. Wrong button.
How'd you get the documentation to show up?
Good question. Question. Here.
Yep.
So I could query
SpaceX ship.
I don't know why my autocomplete isn't working.
It normally works on this
ship. Oh, ships. Okay. Let's do ships.
So
this is a list of all the spaceships.
Right?
Mhmm.
And we can get
active
class.
What else? Mission. Oh, no. It's gonna be
a nested object and I don't wanna have
to find the docs for it. So
let's do this.
Cool.
So let me try and understand
then.
This
GraphQL starter thing that we have here
is configured by the dot WunderGraph directory
where we have this operations file.
Nope. Not that one. Where
did it where was API
What what when the graph config Yes. So
here you can define
any GraphQL
API,
have a introspect and
then make it available over one single API
endpoint. This is what this demo is showcasing.
How we could speak to a country's API,
a weather API, and a SpaceX API, expose
them over one
API for you to query.
Yes. And if you make, like, a new
line here and you type introspect
and dot,
you can see we can also introspect
Apollo Federation,
MongoDB,
MySQL,
OpenAPI
with a file so we could supply an
OpenAPI file and then PlanetScale,
Postgres, SQLite, and SQL Server.
Okay. So these are the compatible
data sources we can introspect and add to
our
virtual graph.
Nice. Okay. Well, not just GraphQL. I could
speak to a whole bunch of databases,
Postgres and MySQL being pretty popular, PlanetScale's in
there too.
And I guess MongoDB for people playing with
Atlas.
Yeah. It's pretty neat. So
you mentioned like
these get versions.
Like,
how are these versions? Like, you talked about
them as sorry. Not version, but as dependencies.
Right? So is that what you mean when
we say we break this in as a
dependency?
Yes. So you introspect them here, and then
at the bottom in line 30, you see
configure WunderGraph application.
And here, we can add our
APIs,
and then we can configure code generators,
course for a our API gateway. We can
configure authentication,
security.
For example, here, we can enable or disable
the GraphQL endpoint.
And,
yeah, at the end of the day, this
gives us our API gateway. But as I
said before,
you almost
don't notice
that you're using an API gateway.
Okay.
So I'm curious
because this was obviously an example from your
repository.
If I am a developer tomorrow and I
want to bring WunderGraph into my application,
how much of this is generated and how
much of this is stuff that I need
to type to, you know, provide the boilerplate
and the glue for this to work?
Yeah. So the generated folder
is generated.
What you need is
the WunderGraph
config TS
and the operations
TS,
and I think there's a third file.
It's just a bit small. Here, you can
configure defaults for your operations, for example. Yes.
And this one
is the hooks configuration.
So, for example, if you want to do
something
before or after
the Dragon's operation is being called, you can
define hooks here
using TypeScript, and then you can hook into
the life cycle of an operation.
So we have a command. I think it's
something
like Wunder CTL in it or something similar.
I think create
WunderGraph app in it,
and that scaffolds you these couple of files.
And that's more or less what you need,
and and the rest is just, just,
yeah, NPM start, and everything else is is
generated.
So it's it's pretty lightweight.
Okay.
What are these operations
then?
Like, if we've already introspect the remote APIs
and we've got the ability to query them,
what what is the operation? Is that as
constraining
the different types of queries or or I
don't know. I'm I'm not gonna guess. I'll
let you go.
Yeah.
The operations folder
defines
our
JSON RPC router.
So for example, we have in the root,
we have
I don't know. It's so small. It's like
countries. Right? Yep. Countries, dragons, or weather.
Okay. So if you open a curl
in terminal
and you do
http
colon slash slash
local host nine nine nine one,
and then slash operations,
and then
dragons.
Yeah. With capital d. Sorry.
Now we're calling
this file, more or less,
or we're calling the operation that was defined
in this file.
Right.
Okay.
And you could also do you have a
Postman installed,
by the way?
No.
Okay.
That that's unfortunate. But I I can just
tell you, if you go to the generator
sure. I could do a preinstall Postman.
Okay.
It won't take long.
Yeah.
We
can use the time. Go to your
go to your playground where you created your
own operation because
you can have your own
operation. So copy this thing here.
Yep. Yes. And now go to the operations
folder,
create a new file, and let's call this
ships or whatever you want inside the operations
folder. Right? Yeah. Ships dot GraphQL.
That's the convention. Okay. Save it.
Great. And now let's call
ships
in call.
Ah, Rawkode. Okay. Yeah.
Yes. That's
Yeah. Okay. So that's the the bit of
information
that I think was important there for me
is because
when we have this graphical playground, the graphical
playground style setup,
we can make any arbitrary query we want
against any of the APIs that have been
introspective or made available via the proxy.
But actually,
really what these people what developers should be
doing is
defining all the different queries as operations
and consuming them from the RPC
API and Yes. Rather than speaking directly.
Yeah.
Go go to the front end code, like
the where you've called
the Dragon's API from the front end.
Yes.
So
when you go to operation name and you
you remove dragons and you
trigger auto completion
Oh,
hey. That's cool.
That's Rawkode.
And now if you check, for example, in
line 10, you make a new line and
you check what dragons contains
data,
And you see what
data is actually inside
this thing.
Hey. That's pretty nice.
And,
you know,
now the audience would think, yeah, yes, cogeneration
exists.
Sure.
Everything exists. It's just a question of do
you want to care or do you want
to have something
that
just works and that figured out all the
hard details? And for example, we we don't
reinvent the wheel. We integrate with
SWR
and React Curry.
So we have other examples that
wrap
WunderGraph,
the WunderGraph TypeScript client, which is TypeSave,
and we wrap this with SWR and React
Query.
So you get the benefits of React Query
with WunderGraph RPC functions.
And you can
you can just call your virtual graph and
you
you know, if you look at this, you
might be thinking I'm doing GraphQL. Right? It
it looks like GraphQL. It feels like GraphQL.
It's not GraphQL, and you don't
care. And it's secure. And for example, if
you define
a an input, go let's go back to
that's a great exercise. Let's make this more
dynamic. Go to your Rawkode operation.
Does SpaceX ships? Does it if you if
you does it have any kind of input?
Like, can we can we
on ships, can we define any kind of
dynamic
parameter?
Let's see.
Yes. It's got find and it's got limits,
offsets, and sorts. So I guess we could
Let let let's just add a limit or
something.
Okay.
So let's test this works. Let's do limit
five.
No. We we need to define
a I I well, I just wanted to
make sure it worked in this API first.
Okay. Okay.
Right. Yeah. Okay. So this is our new
operation.
Make it
but not not hard code. Make it a
variable. So you define a variable after query.
Okay. You know GraphQL bit. Right? Yeah.
Are you not the variable starts with the
dollar. Yeah.
I I I can't remember the exact syntax,
but it seems to be yelling at you.
It is offset and then colon,
and I guess it needs to be int.
Oh, yeah. Okay. Cool.
Yes.
Is that correct?
It's just claiming that it's a
capital I. Capital I. Yep.
Okay.
And those are optional? Right.
Okay. Copy this into your Rawkode operation.
Okay. Save it. Now let's go to curl
and
run it again
like before.
Okay? And,
like, go cursor up
so we can type it again.
And then add a current parameter
offset,
for example, or whatever it was.
Did that work? May maybe we need to
do, like, limit, I think.
Yeah. Let's do one.
Yes.
So now we've created a rest API that
takes those parameters. Try to set limit equals
true.
That's a bad request because we have JSON
schema validation on this endpoint
that validates it must be a number.
Okay.
I wanna make sure I understand this correctly.
Every time we define an operation,
we're writing GraphQL
as a way to spec whatever APIs are
being stitched together by the API proxy.
Behind the scenes, this is actually generating
the
TypeScript
SDK or client
based on all of the type inferences that
can make against those different things, Which is
why we have the ability
to say from here
to
understand what this actually
returns.
I'm How
do I
can I add the limit as a query
parameter to Yeah? That that should be field.
It's called, I think, input.
Yep.
And it's all typed as well. That is
really cool.
I like that because then I could just
I I don't remember how to write code
anymore. I don't know if I say that
enough, but I rely on Versus code and
language server protocols and type systems
more now than ever. And I've been doing
this for twenty years. Like, it just I
I now just fall back on it because
it's just so easy, and it's usually smarter
than I am, which I really appreciate. So
yeah. But, you know, let let's say so
now we have this operation.
And let let's say the result
that we're getting back,
it is not making us happy. We we
want to customize it. We want to do
better.
We should go fully custom because we want
to manipulate the data before returning to the
client. Right?
Okay.
Let's create
a TypeScript function to do that.
So if we go to our operations directory.
Mhmm.
Create a TypeScript file
with a unique name we didn't use before,
so not Rawkode again.
And Jens.
Yance. Okay. Awesome.
And then you start typing
create
export default.
Sorry. That's a convention export default.
Create operation.
What's a create operation?
Just type create operation.
Yeah. Import this and then dot
query
and then
function
with input and stuff. Yeah. Make an object,
create a handler. It's an async func
that takes
yes.
Copilot is kind of driving. Copilot
is great. And return
an object like hello or whatever you want.
Okay. And save this. Uh-huh. Awesome. And go
to your front end
code
and call Jens
as operation name.
Now we're getting the the our inputs are
invalid.
I'm assuming because there's none. So
Just remove. Yeah. Okay. So does that mean
we can That's
our front end now. Yeah. Call it.
Let's call it. Yes.
Okay.
So before, we were like, okay.
We're talking API dependencies.
Now we want to build something custom.
And next step is you put it together.
So you go back to your Yen's function,
and
there you have the CTX.
So
make some room for a CTX dot
internal client
dot
query
queries
and then
Rawkode.
And that's
an async
thing.
Yeah. Limit to whatever you want. Okay.
And put it into an object, like, const
what you want,
and then you can do some manipulation.
It's yelling at me because it's the potential
undefeigned nature, obviously.
Ships is ships?
What I'll do is add just a response
data.
What's that?
Oh, it could be undefined.
Alright. Well, TypeScript is pretty smart. So as
long as we say,
return blah,
that frees this up.
And we can map over all the ships
and join.
But I could just join. I could not.
No. Because I need the name.
I think after ships, you need a question
mark.
But the map should work over and I
the map should work on an empty list.
Right?
But it's not an empty list.
It can be undefined.
Oh, yeah. Let's try calling this.
Alright. Let's change the limit.
Cool.
So using these completely TypeScript based handlers,
we can
call any of the other
queries through this internal client, which gives us
back the typed response. We can
mutate that data however we want and then
spread it straight back in.
That's pretty cool. Go to your front end
code.
Uh-huh.
And
add an input.
Like ah, no. We we don't yet have
an input. Right? Let's
let's go back to the to the function.
Let's go back to the function.
Yes.
Yeah. Add an input, and that's a
Zot object. So besides import, create operation, after
create operation, just add comma Zot.
Mhmm. And then create an object.
And here, we can
we we could make a limit, like and
make it a number. Right?
Yeah. Z number.
Okay. And then instead of passing five, pass
CTX input
limit.
Yep.
Go to your front end.
And add the input object.
Okay.
Submit.
Does our front end work?
No. Because
we changed the data structure.
Oh.
Although it's actually not complaining about the data
structure. It's complaining about
random other stuff. So maybe it does work.
How do I get to the front end?
It was
Local host
CK, I think.
Yeah. It's working.
Okay.
And now something interesting
that we
where we took some inspiration from tRPC.
If you go back to your function
where we call it the the input
for example, if you change number
just out of like, it doesn't make sense,
but change number to stream
and go to your front end code
no. The front end code. Sorry.
And go to the input.
You will see it pops an arrow immediately,
and that's
because we're exposing
or
we infer
the TypeScript types
from the
Zot object definition,
and we export it with
export type
and import type into the front end behind
the scenes. Like, you didn't see that. If
you look into generated
Next. Js, you will see it actually.
But we have a direct connection between
front end code and and back end code,
and that gives you this immediate
feedback loop if you're creating TypeScript functions.
Yeah. That's one of those big selling points
about tRPC that people always rave about is
the fact that you get this consistency
across the types
for back end and front end. And it
is it's
Yeah. Very cool.
So what what you get here is a
smooth
transition between
oh, I just create
I
I I just create a
graph to operation. That's enough.
Until you reach a point where you say,
it needs to be customized. I need to
call five APIs and combine them in a
certain way, and I want to manipulate the
data because it's not in the right shape
we need for the front end.
And then you go
the TypeScript route,
and you can always choose, like, what is
the way to go. But you see from
the front end experience,
like, front end client,
it doesn't didn't change a bit. It is
the same experience, and that's what we're trying
to do. We try to make a very
smooth
transition between I'm just calling a service and
it's fine. The way the data comes back
is okay.
Two, I need to build something custom.
But from a client perspective, it's the same
interface. Nothing new to learn, nothing to change.
Yeah.
It's
it's really interesting because WunderGraph
is in this space where I can't really
work out
who it competes with because it does so
much. Like,
do you,
you know, as a founder,
right, do you see WunderGraph as competing with
the likes of Hasura or with TRPC
with with both with Take? Like,
what where do you where do you position
it? Where do you feel that this is?
This is a WunderGraph question.
WunderGraph
is in the category
where you collapse
seven tools into one, and you're like
Yeah. I
you know?
So I'm now,
I don't know, more than ten years in
in IT,
and I learned so many things about,
this is what I said before, why I
created WunderGraph. So many things I hate
doing,
because it's boring and repetitive.
And WunderGraph is the result that gives you
in the end the stack
where you where you don't have to do
the the mundane
things again. Like, you know, the way we
just transitioned between TypeScript and GraphQL,
the same way you could now add an
OpenID Connect provider like all zero,
and
then you have authentication.
And what is special
about WunderGraph here is
we kind of, in some way, like obviously,
it's not the the main purpose, but we
are similar to something like Firebase,
but we don't
dictate
a specific back end. You can you can
say, I have my GraphQL. I have my
REST. I have my database.
We don't tell you where those need to
be and which provider.
We also don't tell you what authentication
provider to use. It could be Azure. It
could be Clerk.
With WunderGraph, you can glue it together
in a coherent
developer experience
that feels like
it is Firebase,
but the components
can be anything that you bring.
And so we
we're kind of like an anti vendor login
login tool.
At the same time, it feels like we
are a vendor lock in tool
because it feels like it's one experience,
but you can bring the components,
you know, if that makes sense.
Yeah. Definitely.
So
I'm trying to think of some
use cases that I think are quite novel
and interesting here.
One of the things that always frustrates me
about
GraphQL
is
aggregate root functions,
like trying to get counts while creating data.
I think it's very difficult to kind of
stitch those things together.
I'm curious, can we
can we try and do that with WunderGraph
and see what others like? What I mean
is what I'd really love to be able
to do and this might be so easy
that you're just gonna go like, sure. But
what if we query all the dragons,
get in their names,
but also return
the
number of active dragons as well as the
number of total dragons. Like
to me, if I were doing this with
GraphQL, it would be a bit of a
pain.
I'm curious if we can make that a
nice
API with Wunder Graph. Does that make sense?
Yeah. I get it. But
I I would love to show off
one feature of WunderGraph.
Maybe we can do a cross API join.
That sounds
even more exciting. Let's do that.
Okay.
Can you go to the WunderGraph config TS?
Want to check if we have the dependencies
we need.
Okay. We have countries. We have better. Okay.
Let's create
a new operation. We call it join.
Alright. Is that a TypeScript or GraphQL operation?
GraphQL.
Okay. And let's start with countries.
Countries and then countries.
No. Just do countries country. Otherwise, I don't
want to make too many API calls.
Yeah.
Country.
ID, name, and capital.
Alright. So don't think IDs are too much.
Yeah. ID is cool. And it takes a
parameter, I think, the country code.
Yeah. Code. Make that a variable.
I think it's ID capital ID.
No.
No. No. The instead of string, it should
be capital ID. Oh, sorry. Alright. Okay.
Yeah. ID is a very weird scalar in
GraphQL because it can be according to the
specification,
it can be a string or a number.
Like,
it's kind of like a union.
You know, we we we're talking about input
unions for seven hundred years already, and they
still are not in the spec. But we
already have an input union, which is ID.
It can be
int or,
yeah, number or string. Okay. So that's our
starting point. Let's curl it. Or no. You
installed Postman. Let's Postman it.
Now it's time for Postman.
Okay.
Click import.
I've never just put some before. Give me
a moment. Where's import? Oh, there we go.
Oh, yeah. There. And select our generated
directory
from our project in the examples
thingy.
What's it called? Dot oh, dot WunderGraph. Right?
Yep.
It's not finding it.
Are you in the directory of the project?
No. It's in the examples. Yeah. Yeah. Alright.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Examples then types Next. Js TypeScript functions, I
think.
Generate
it.
So the whole generated directory?
No. Generate it. There should be some file
a JSON file with Postman in the name.
Like, I don't know, something postman collection. Directory,
so maybe we need to do this.
Oh, come on.
How do we show dot files on this
thing?
Control shift dot.
Control.
Alright.
No. I don't think it
I'm gonna Google it.
Mac OS finder tool dot files.
Or is it command shift dot?
Let me check.
Maybe it just doesn't work in this little.
Was let's drag it in.
Yeah. You can drag it also.
Who'd have thought Mac OS finder would be
our downfall?
Yeah. It's okay. So dot fails work from
here. Just not in that little thing. Okay.
So generated
and then we wanna post man JSON.
Yeah. That's good.
Cool. And then pop up WunderGraph queries.
And what was
is it to join? Okay. And now you
can call.
Ah, yeah. You need to click the button
for code
and put
some code.
Okay.
We have London.
That's the starting point. So that that's that's
for the people who like to share an
API they've created.
So WunderGraph,
by default, creates a Postman collection in the
generated folder from all your operations. In that
way, you can send the Postman collection to
your to your users, and now you can
they can explore your
your REST API you created.
Nice. I like it. So now we're gonna
add the weather to this. Right? Yeah. Now
now we want weather for a capital. So
after codes,
you make a little space, and we need
new variable, which is going to be no.
After code in the in the variable definition.
Yeah. We make a city variable, which is
a string.
And after the variable, we type an at
at
internal.
No. Not internal operation, just at internal.
Yes. Okay. That makes
that's something it's a it's a convention. But
this means we now have a space
to store something.
And after capital in line four,
you can now write at export
right
behind
capital
In line four after Capital.
Not before, after.
Sorry.
Bet you went through it. Done the typing,
though.
Yeah. It's a it's a yes. Just follow
Postman.
Copilot.
Copilot. Yes. So when we execute the field
capital,
we export
the value into
the variable. Oh, not capital, but city.
Export it into city.
Okay.
And now we use another
feature that is WunderGraph specific.
So make a new line after line four
and type underscore join.
Yes.
And then, like, braces and stuff.
And what it does is
join embeds
a second query type. Like, remove this on
stuff. It's wrong.
Like
yeah. So this embeds a second query
into the first. So now you can start
with weather.
Weather gets city by name,
and then,
yeah, just pick some fields.
Weather,
blah blah, summary, temperature.
I think you need to select on summary.
Description.
Yep.
Icon title.
This is Yep.
Wind. Okay. We get it. I have a
query. Cool.
Okay. Save this. I don't have to look
up any documentation for this API whatsoever. I
was just all complete in my way through
every moment. That that's that's fun. And by
the way, the more you use
the more you use
Copilot for this, like, for me, I don't
know why, but for me, it's
auto completes weather and stuff automatically.
Like, it somehow knows about these APIs already.
Okay. So let's go back to Postman?
Yes.
And just call it.
Yeah. That's it.
We joined two APIs.
Nice.
It's almost like magic.
Almost.
Like, it's it's kinda like a join, but
not tables, but across APIs.
Yeah. And it just reflects the structure of
this this query here. So I'm assuming, like,
the GraphQL approach,
you can throw these things together pretty quickly.
And if you want to change the shape
of it, you just create the TypeScript function
and call it that way.
Because I'm assuming we could do the exact
same in TypeScript with,
let's see.
So if I wanted to get the city
I'm feeling too brave now. That's just gonna
be my downfall.
Country
input
codes.
I'm not gonna worry about the variables.
So that should fetch my city and then
I could do weather.
And there is a question coming, but I'm
trying to
get through this first.
City,
which is going to be our city dot
data
capital
name,
or maybe that is the name.
Yeah. Mhmm.
And then my response
could just be whatever shape of data I
want. So we'll call this
capital
and
temperature.
It's complaining. It's it's ridiculous.
City is probably
requesting
a string, not string, or undefined. Right?
I mean, I guess I could just default
this to the
Something is wrong with weather and temperature.
Oh.
Ah,
can see by name.
You see, Copilot needs to learn a a
little more about
what you're doing here.
Okay.
So now our Yen's API
could take an input, but I've hard coded
it to GP, which is then gonna go
fetch the weather. And then I define the
shape of the data that gets turned back
to the client. So if we come to
Jens
I broke it.
No. You need to put an input.
You're ignoring it, but it's still in the
in the JSON schema validation.
See, this
is very interesting.
Like, that
was just so easy
to decide that I want to expose two
bits of information to people when they give
me a country code because I want to
tell them the name of the capital and
the actual
temperature.
And I could just dictate that. Like now
we have the system.
You know, let me back up a bit.
So I wanna make sure that I
get the importance of this in my header
graph. It's like, we have this divide. Right?
And I'll use a product like asura as
a demonstration here. Right? Really great product, but
very
operational centric. Like, you know, some team manages
that. They connect it to a database to
define the schema.
Like, a front end developer is not going
to come along,
modify the Hasura metadata to expose the data
that they want in the format that they
want, etcetera.
But WunderGraph changes that because we have this
TypeScript API to everything, which is very familiar
to both back end developers, full stack developers
or front end developers.
Where it can coexist in a model repository
with a generated client let's say by say,
is that the front end developer can come
along and say, actually, I want an API
endpoint that returns data as it looks like
this. They stretch a few things together and
they've got what they need and they can
do it all in the same pull request
and update their client code at the same
time.
And that's an enabler that I just don't
think these other products offer in this space.
And I hope that that makes sense to
people and it's not just waffle dribbling out
my mouth, but it's just such a powerful
feature.
Yeah. You know, one more thing. Now go
to the front end code
and check what is the response shape gonna
look like.
Like, here, we call Jens. So it's the
name is dragons and check what is the
the response type of dragons. So if you
in line 15, if you type dragons
or here yeah.
Data.
You see you have capital and and temperature.
That's what we returned from our API.
Mhmm.
Nice.
I could have a lot of fun with
that.
Yeah.
Alright. Sorry. I just see everybody's
comments trying to tell me how to show
the the dot fails. Thank you, everybody.
Yeah.
You have a helpful community.
Alright.
Abdul saying, and no need for a GUI
like Hasura. Yeah. I mean, Azure you use
the web interface to configure everything or you
can use your YAML metadata. It's a bit
awkward
and especially for me when I do want
everything to be code.
It's like my my default now is just
gonna be not to ship Azure anywhere and
just to create a WunderGraph API
because then I have this dynamic ability to
duplicate my queries if I want with different
names, version them if I wanted to because
we could do that as code and change
the shape of things by writing these TypeScript
handlers.
Like, it's just
very nifty. I think it
alright. You know the the Sorry. I only
go. Just just to comment on this. The
problem with
user interfaces is
if someone wants to
replicate what we just did,
you just type the code. You can you
can follow the code. If we had to
click buttons,
you cannot store button clicks in Git.
If you want to follow what we just
did here, the combination,
the the all this stuff, you can now
put it in a Git repo,
and everybody would understand
how we change these operations, how we define
the Yance
operation. Like, everything is in Git. It is
versioned automatically.
If you click buttons,
you first have to think about, okay, how
can we do, like, a
revision or embed a revision system into the
user interface so that people can understand what
changes
were made to the system last night because
this morning, everything is breaking?
Yep. So everything in WunderGraph, everything you change
to your WunderGraph application, it's visible because you
it's code. You put it in Git. There's
there's no GUI because
I don't want a GUI. You know, everything
we just did, we we always kept typing,
and it was efficient. And we have this
is what I said in the beginning. TypeScript
is the interface
for developers.
It's the perfect developer interface. We don't need
buttons or GUIs.
We we need good
TypeScript definitions so that we don't have to
think about what is limit. Is it a
number?
The IDE tells you. You,
you know, you can just type away. Also,
GraphQL with its amazing
auto completion,
just type away. You know?
Alright. We're getting
pretty close to time, and I've been I've
been showing things that I just thought were
interesting. Is there anything else from these example
repositories that you would like to show people
before we finish up today?
No. I think we're pretty much at the
core. Like, you could now add
You could add more services like federation,
stuff like that. In the end, the the
DX would be very similar.
Like, you know, you have use query here.
You could also import use auth.
And whatever auth provider you add,
you can just call it. You don't have
to add any other dependencies.
No. I think
we're we're
ah,
Ray just mentioned directives.
Yeah. Okay. We we can talk about role
based access if if you want. Like, okay.
We we don't have enough time for adding
authentication now. But if you go to one
of the operations,
like dragons,
for example,
And after dragons, you type at
r back.
Yes. And then
open, like,
open the function. Yes. And you
could say require match all
and make an array.
And inside this array, admin.
Yep.
Save it
and call this function, and you will see
it will
not work because
we don't have role admin.
Four
zero one. Yeah. So you could now add
an authentication provider,
and we have a callback function
like a hook where when someone authenticates,
you can write the TypeScript function to give
them roles, and you can define what roles
exist in your realm.
And now you could say, okay.
If
my name is Rawkode or my email is
something Rawkode
whatever,
I give myself the role admin, and then
you would be allowed to actually use this
this operation. But
Yeah. Must admit that's possible in in a
TypeScript
too.
Type you can write CTX user,
and you can say roles.
And Or includes.
Yes. Something, I guess.
How do I return, like, a four zero
one then?
Yeah. That's
the missing feature I'm currently working on.
Alright. Like, we released functions
Tuesday
this week. Oh, wow. And
Okay. So that's pretty fresh off the okay.
Yeah. Yeah. It it's it's pretty fresh, and
we need to add
a way of
returning unauthorized.
But yeah.
Oh, I've got if it does include admin.
Okay. So
so that should give me an error.
Yeah. I think it will actually time out
because
we're we're not yet
properly handling those errors.
You you you caught us on the on
the alpha stage here. Hey. You gave me
TypeScript functions, and I I wanna start using
them for everything now. So I'm gonna I'll
get a feature request in for the ability
to augment this Alright.
That's awesome. Let me put us back into
to big face mode. So what I would
say is if you have any questions and
you're watching, you've got a couple of minutes
to drop them in to the chat. Well,
Jens and I have a quick conversation.
So just
first, thank you. This is a really cool
project. I've got so many different cases that
I want. Literally,
you know, I reached out because I was
experimenting with using this. Have real things that
I want to do with it. And I
just thought, you know what, this is cool.
So thank you for spending time with me
today and showing us this. And why don't
you give us a little bit of a
flavor on
where you're going with WunderGraph? Like, what does
the next three months or six months look
like? What are your priorities?
What's coming down the line for people that
are curious?
Yes. So
in the next couple of weeks, we launch
the
so our cloud is currently in alpha stage.
We launch our cloud
to to beta,
which means
from like, you now have a repo with
the dot WunderGraph folder.
And
in in
WunderGraph cloud, you select this repo from your
Git repo,
and then everything gets deployed automatically
in whatever location you want.
You get analytics.
You get edge caching.
You get, like, what you would expect
from an API deployment
thing.
And what's on the road map is, like,
we want to bring collaboration so we can
work with the team. We want to closely
integrate with services like Vercel.
So your front end on Vercel, your back
end on WunderGraph.
And another
from super important thing for me is when
you integrate APIs,
what
is kind of like
apparent is
it doesn't always work.
Like, let's say you have an operation.
It needs to call into three services
to to to complete the workflow, like get
some data from Stripe,
put some data in your database, and then
call another service to to send an email
and and whatnot. And this can fail sometimes.
What we are also bringing to WunderGraph is
something
quite similar to
temporal.
So I call this feature WunderGraph machines,
which will be resilient
state machines,
essentially. So background workers, but not background workers
as you think,
like, much more elegant,
kind of like a
React component,
but it's a state machine.
And you can retry things, and you can
design long running operations and workflows and and
crons.
And we will also be adding an event
system, so like a pops up system where
you can,
for example, send an event to a WunderGraph
machine, and it can react to that because
it's a state machine.
And
you can subscribe to events
by a state machine,
which gives you a whole new way of
designing
applications.
And all this, again,
TypeScript interface, very elegant.
You can call it from your functions,
etcetera.
And the the the real purpose here is
to
you know,
most people, when we talk about APIs, we
talk about, okay. Let's create some cruds things,
and that's that's really the simple stuff. But
what the developer experience, I want to create
is resilient,
long running state machines where
if a user signs up
with your SaaS application,
you can actually create a state machine for
this user,
and you can send
events to this state machine whenever you want,
and this can transition the state machine into
different states. Like, for example, if you want
to to create something like, you
can have a state machine for your organization.
And if someone wants to join this organization,
you can send it an event. So in
a a state machine or a WunderGraph machine,
it will have, like, a storage. And it's
what's also very important is it's going to
be serverless.
So you don't have to think about where
does it run. Does it actually run? Is
it sleeping or or whatnot? Because it can
sleep, and it will cost you nothing if
it sleeps.
And the whole thing is to rethink
APIs and and workflows because sometimes, you know,
when we do a deployment
in WunderGraph,
what we do is we go to fly.io.
That's our the provider where we run our
stuff on, and we do a bunch of
API calls. Like, we create an app an
an
application. They call this application.
Then you create a fly machine.
You have
to build an image. You have to deploy
that image, and this takes for the first
run about two minutes and subsequent
builds around, like, twenty seconds.
And this is a very long running operation.
And similar to temporal,
we want to allow you to build
in a very, like, elegant way,
kind of like React components,
but without returning HTML,
just return state.
We want to allow you to build resilient
state machines so that you you can define
workflows. You can define crumbs. You can,
yeah, just define state in your opera in
your application in a whole new way, and
it's going to be fun. Like,
you know, it's it's such a pain in
the ass if you want to build something
like
WunderGraph today,
and you have to integrate with partners like
Fly,
you have to.
It is so hard to build resilient
functions. Like, you cannot just call Fly and
everything flies because sometimes it doesn't.
How do you retry? How do you and,
of course, I can have temporal, but now
I need someone who understands temporal and deploys
it. Or do I use the cloud, and
how do I embed it into my thing?
And what I really just want to do
is, you know, I call my from my
front end, I can call the function. And
from my function, I can call a WunderGraph
machine, and that's everything I need. And so
we really try to
to unpack
the hard things into
super
simple solutions that everybody can understand. And I
think even a front end developer with some
experience will be able to build
resilient
workflows and long running operations
with WunderGraph machines.
So that's what's going to come in the
next month.
And the next month?
Wow.
Or months. Yeah.
Months.
Alright.
We'll definitely have to get something else scheduled
then to
do a follow-up. I would love to. That
would be amazing.
I have one question in the comments, and
then I'll let you go because I know
that's also getting quite late for you over
there. But Abdul is asking, what other data
sources are on your road map for WunderGraph?
Yes. So
currently,
I would say
something that is very interesting for us is
gRPC and async API
or more specifically Kafka.
So super interesting. By the way, we also
want to expose
gRPC
from WunderGraph. So recently, we thought about,
like
you know, we have those
those JSON RPC operations,
which we currently like, we have our own
spec, how we do JSON RPC,
and we can create a Postman collection,
it would actually be quite simple for us
to also add a gRPC endpoint,
which means everybody who
can generate a gRPC client in Python,
Ruby, Java, whatever, can call your WunderGraph API.
So you get a hell lot more options
for people to call your API. I think
that's amazing.
And regarding origins,
yeah, I think Kafka and and message
brokers like RabbitMQ,
super important
that you can go, like, async.
And also gRPC
just as an internal system. I think that's
that's very important.
By the way, one one thing I forgot
to mention for the road map is we
are also going to be focusing a lot
on WunderGraph
help in the future. You know, when we
started talking it, I I spoke about
API dependencies
and the API package manager.
And one one core feature of WunderGraph
that we wanna focus more in the future
is actually sharing APIs. Like, when you do
introspect GraphQL and introspect something else,
it means that you need to
be able to introspect those.
But
what if someone could just share an NPM
package with you,
and that's your import, and it will be
type safe out of the box? So what
we're building is like an NPM
for APIs where I can
build a collection of my internal APIs,
publish them to the hub, and the rest
of my team or another company, they can
then import those APIs and add them to
their retrographic.
That's that makes
using and reusing APIs
a lot or or sharing a a lot
easier, and we we want to to definitely
also focus on on that end.
Yeah. Just
give people a way of
sharing APIs.
You know, sharing is caring.
Awesome.
Well, thank you for sharing that road map
with us as well. And it's great to
see I mean, there's a lot of really
interesting stuff there that you're trying to tackle.
The state machine temporal thing is something again
that resonates. I think we play with all
the same technologies. That's that's what our current
team I'm seeing here is that we have
very similar interests. I host my own temporal
cluster on a Kubernetes cluster.
And it's hard. And but I want the
semantics
because temporal has this concept of activities where
you have this guarantee that things could be
retried if they fail and and really strict
error handling.
And I do want an easier API for
that. Like, I don't want to host my
own temporal. So consider me user number one
for when you have something there with the
the state. You know, we we just defined
a TypeScript function. Right?
And I believe
creating a resilient workflow
should be as simple as creating
another TypeScript functions.
And
with WunderGraph Cloud,
you don't deploy anything, and you you don't
even switch context. You just create,
like, a I don't know, export default,
create machine
something, and it
will be resilient. And
that's just it, like, yeah,
don't worry about stuff. Get you you know,
like, for your business purpose, how much does
it actually matter?
And is it not a waste of time?
And we know the answer is yes, that
you run your own Kubernetes cluster and temporal.
Like, you know, it can break. You have
to understand temporal. Maybe they there's something, like,
you need to patch it. Like, I guess
it's a great exercise for you to run
it on your own. And I don't know.
Like, running Kubernetes
on your own is, like, such a pain
in the ass. Like, everything can go wrong.
And
if
you're building you know, this is the thing
you've you only learn if you're a startup
founder.
You have so much pressure.
You really want to outsource
everything that has nothing to do with your
business. So for us, I would never allow
anybody to run
a Kubernetes cluster if we if we are
not past, like, series a or something and
we have so much money
that we
really don't care. You know?
I mean, teaching people Kubernetes is
pretty much where 90% of my income comes
from helping people operate Kubernetes. So I I
really do need to be good at it.
So Okay. Yeah. That in in that case,
oh, obviously. Sure. It as a teacher, it
makes sense. But temporal, though, I don't I
don't have to be running my own temporal
cluster, and I prefer not to. But I
am I I've loosed the pricing of temporal
cloud and like fuck that. Like, there's no
way I'm giving them that money when I
can fight it myself. So
alright.
Again, thank you so much for spending time
with me. Really cool project. We'll definitely reach
out in a month when you have the
state machine stuff ready. I'm gonna hold you
to that date now. I'll set it up
a flyer somewhere and we'll get Yes. Scheduled.
But have a wonderful evening.
Go spend some time with your kids if
it's not their bedtime yet, and I will
speak to you again soon.
Thank you, man. Well, super cool. Have
a great day. Bye.